>>
Role models are very important in the Middle
East. We are extremely in need of hope and
people expressing a lot of what they can overcome
from all those difficulties. For instance,
and I think now, as a Jew and Rabbi, about
the conflict with the Isreali's and Palestinians,
and the ripped families, these people who
really suffer on both sides of war and attacks
and suppression and lose, lost there really
loved ones who cooperate together in peace
and hold each other's hands and go on thinking
of ways and doing things to increase peace.
These are extremely important role models.
And you know, in my life, I was born during
the second World War and saved by a Catholic
woman who was 47 years old and when I speak
about my own experience. For instance, when
living with Rabbi's and Iman's a few years
ago, to pray together for peace suddenly the
mood changes. It's, here's an example, this
is of course in business, in culture, in not
only people who achieve greatness, but people
who find dignity and share dignity with others.
And I've seen it, mostly in my work in schools
that we ask for their respect and people of
the community come into the classroom and
discuss, how do you give respect, how do you
receive respect. And these are people who
are accomplished musicians, are anethesitists,
just simple people around the corner who work
with like Bill Gates. When they speak about
how their own life, how they went through
mistakes and this illusion have kept hope
and then achieved what they have achieved.
That helps the young people to go forward.
So in short, role models, we see it in sports,
we see it in the media, we see it in people
who are exceptional, how it works. Role models
are very important all through the world of
Islam, the world of Judism, Christianity where
we sometimes see the bad effect of religion
and inter-religous actions that's not how
it works. To see role models where it works
when you have [inaudible] and dignity you
are creating an image of hope. So please continue
to be role models and find hope.